this program is being presented to you
by the hereas international winter
school on gravity and light
well thanks frederick and cora for
inviting me
so this is an even lecture on on the
difficult relation between quantum
theory in general and
in gravity
and as you might know there is no
no consistent theory of quantum gravity
and it's not even unanimously shared in
opinion that there should be one
and
i give you some reasons along the lines
of this talk so since this is an even
nature i sort of
erased
some of the more technical parts
and tried to convey some ideas i will be
of course formally but
i think the emphasis should be really on
the ideas
that lie between somewhere quantum
theory and gravity
so let me start by by a famous drawing
it's called the bronzedine cube
which is often given in this context
which is a cube that has um lies in the
corner of a three-dimensional coordinate
system and each axis has a natural
constant
to it which is the the planck's constant
newton's constant g and the inverse
velocity of light
and in a very very rough sense and i'm
not saying this is this is a a very a
very useful picture it's a in as a rough
picture it's quite useful
you can understand the the fundamental
theories that we that we have
by
kind of um
uh supposing that um you switch on these
these these constants from the zero
value on to some finite value
so in some sense from classical
mechanics
um
you get two not uniquely but you you get
to quantum mechanics by switching on age
there is a there's a underlying
mathematical theory called deformation
theory deformation quantization
which
kind of makes it mathematically precise
how to go along this way
how to deform the poisson algebra of
observables in the classical theory to
the
algebra of observables in quantum theory
likewise if you go from classical
mechanics to special relativity this
somehow corresponds to deforming
galilei invariants
so from the galileo group you can
actually get in a systematic fashion to
the poincare group
by
deforming it the converse is called
contraction
so there is a deformation of the
invariance group of classical mechanics
to the invariance group of special
relativity
and that has to do with switching on one
over c
so give c a finite value rather than an
infinite value
and the third axis is switching on
gravity there is no deformation theory
that gets you from newtonian
gravity to general additivity except
perhaps that in a very very
intuitive way space-time gets deformed
and acquires curvature
but there's no deformation of theories
really
in any way so it's i think the the idea
should be clear that somehow within this
cube several theories can be more or
less uniquely um
located
so i don't want to want to
suggest that this way these these
different paths are always commutative
it's not clear that from classical
mechanics you get a quantum mechanics by
switching on h and then you switch on
one over c and then you get to
relativistic quantum field theory
whereas would you
i'm not saying that it's the same as
first going to special additivity and
then somehow applying some quantization
rules
right
and so the the the last missing part is
that is that um
is that
corner here and that stands for quantum
gravity so all three things are switched
on in a sense
and again i want to emphasize that it is
not obvious that you get to this
hypothetical point in any order of
following these edges perhaps there is
no point at all perhaps you get into
completely different kinds of physics by
following these directions
we don't know
and for most of my talk i will be kind
of be
sitting
somewhere close to quantum mechanics and
trying to go to go up this in this
direction so quantum mechanics plus a
little bit of gravity whatever this
means at the moment just uh so it could
mean quantum mechanical systems in a
gravitational field you just drop
quantum mechanics system or it can mean
quantum mechanics as the source of
gravitational fields
and um you will see this more concretely
as i go along
um
the the numbers that that are floating
around in the literature if people talk
about quantum gravity are always the
planck units so these are units of
length time and mass that you can form
from these three constants that i've
just shown you h bar g and c
and they correspond to incredibly small
distances incredibly small times
and
not so small masses
it's not so small masses
so it's 10 to the minus 5 grams or 10 to
the 19 atomic mass units atomic mass
units is the weight of a proton
and not the weight the the mass of a
proton
and you can motivate why these at at
least these sort of these these in these
at these scales quantum gravity somehow
must become important
for example you could envisage
a black hole whose mass is less than the
planck mass
if a black hole has a mass that is less
than the planck length
at the planck mass
then
its diameter its its horizon diameter is
less than its compton wavelength
now a continent wavelength is the
distance below which you can not really
talk about classical distances the
resolution is not there to actually
resolve some distance smaller than this
so if you if you say that operationally
speaking distances smaller than the
compton wavelength should not be used on
a classical level then you would not say
that a black hole exists beyond this
mass because then you would have
said that the horizon length is smaller
than the compton wavelength which
presumably is meaningless
so if somebody told you that he has
produced a black hole smaller than a
mass of the plank mass you should be
suspicious because probably it doesn't
make any sense
and the smallness of these two numbers
are the sort of the are the the the the
uh embarrass are the embarrassment
of those people who
search for quantum gravity because you
you can you can quite justifiably ask
how would you ever ever get to distances
at this length all times at this small
time how can you beat the blank scale
whoever talks about quantum gravity
should answer the question how he or she
supposes to actually beat these
these ludicrously small small scales
but
as concerns the relation between quantum
mechanics and relativity it's not clear
that this is the final word it's not
clear that you have to go to these to
these scales
it's a kind of sufficient condition so
if you write these clades then probably
um some theory of quantum gravity should
take over but um it's the the converse
does not hold so the converse saying um
presumably you can see
interesting effects that have to do with
quantum theory and gravity
even before you reach these scales
so what is known actually about
the relation between gravity and quantum
mechanics and the answer is very very
little here's two classic
experiments one is the famous kolila
overhausaverna
experiment from 1975
in which you have two beams of neutrons
very very cold neutrons
and they are diffracted in a crystal and
it's a typical
it's a typical um
interference experiment where a particle
the quantum mechanics wave function of a
particle gets coherently split and
travel along two different paths and
then being coherently combined
and the the idea being that one of these
paths
runs in a different gravitational
potential than the other one for example
at a different height and then they are
combined again
and the phase shift that you observe at
the end via the diffraction
pattern
depends on this gravitational on this
difference of the gravitational
potential
and so you can see the interaction
between the gravitation field and the
quantum mechanical delocalized particles
coherently split by the diffraction
pattern
and what has been tested by this
experiment what has been tested is the
most obvious thing that anybody would
write down namely in the schrodinger
equation an interaction term that
consists of the gravitational potential
the potential according to the
gravitational interaction times the wave
function just like any other potential
in the schrodinger equation so what you
see here as a diffraction pattern which
is just a just verifies that this is the
right coupling so this coupling has been
verified in this experiment and it's
quite old as you can see
so it's 40 years old
more recent people took very cold ultra
cold neutrons and produced bound states
in the gravitational field of the earth
so consider a hard mirror
and and um neutrons bouncing on top of
this hard mirror
and since um on the on the um
in the vertical direction there's the
gravitational pull if you make the
nodule very very cold it stays in a in a
bound state between a potential that has
a hard wall and a linear and a linear
slope on the other side
and this is known from elementary
quantum mechanics exercises for example
it's the airy function that solves this
these uh
bound states and um these bound states
in the gravitational field not in
electrophilic gravitation have been seen
and they are separated by the order of
pico electron volts
so it's very very small very very small
steps they have been produced at the
institute of
la javer in geneva
and
i will come back to this experiment uh
later on and again what you see is just
what you get if you put the earth
gravitational potential into the
schrodinger equation in the obvious way
so there seems to be no problem at this
point it's the obvious coupling and that
has been verified
okay
um as the the regarding the question
whether quantum gravity should be um
should be pursued i guess 90 of the
people in the community would say strong
yes of course you should and there are
strong candidates
not entirely satisfactory in all aspects
but their strengths theory loop quantum
gravity and other approaches but they're
also voices of people who actually
pursue the the game of quantum gravity
who sometimes ask the question is
quantum gravity really necessary
and is there perhaps an experiment by
which we can test that it is necessary
or is there perhaps an experiment in
which you can test that it is not
necessary
and that is what this this paper is
about it's from 2008 and in this paper
it is suggested that certain experiments
in
molecular interferometry
might show
that quantum and that's the quantum the
gravitational field has to stay
classical rather than being quantized
and it's um it is suggested in this
paper buying theorists that perhaps one
should look at these interesting
experiments and i will come back to this
this head
has been picked up by other people
and i will
tell you what the idea behind this
proposal is
um and the last
sort of opinion i want to i want to
display is a
fairly recent paper by roger penrose
who who always took the point of you
said why why do we always talk about
quantizing relativity i mean it's always
you take a classical theory and then you
do something with it you
it
undergoes a certain mathematical
procedure and it becomes a quantum zone
so theory so quantum mechanics quantum
chromodynamics quantum electrodynamics
and quantum gravity
perhaps
the union of the two will be such that
the idea of quantum theory is at least
as much changed as gravity will be
changed
and so he says why
so why give quantum theory pride of
place in this proposed union perhaps we
should gravitase quantum theory
whatever this means it's um kind of many
meanings
right so let's let's go a little bit
into the the foundations of of our
theory of gravity and i understand that
you have learned all the the sort of the
the the formal stuff and the the
mathematics
and um in this talk i will um focus a
little bit on the sort of conceptual
backgrounds
and the conceptual background between be
behind
general additivity is the
famous equivalence principle which has
many formulations einstein himself
changed his formulation many times
but the the canonical way to present it
nowadays is in a
um is in a form in which it contains
three
more or less independent parts
the the first part is is presumably that
that you all associate with the um
equivalence principle it's the
universality of free fall or sometimes
express the equality of inertial and
gravitational mass
and it's called off so universality of
free fall
and it says that test bodies and i put
it in in
quotation marks um for reasons that i i
talk about later so test bodies
determine the so-called and that's a
mathematical expression of a path
structure
that means
um
you have all learned about space-time
manifolds and so on so if you take a
point and a direction
on the space-time manifold
then this uniquely determines a path
and that is the path a force-free
particle an otherwise force-free
particle just
interacting gravitationally will follow
on your space-time manifold and that's
in in gr for example it's the geodesic
equation the geographic equation it's a
point in the direction
and once you have a point in direction
there's a unique geodesic following
this
this direction
um the universality of free fall
says that there is something in the
world called test particles which has
virtually no interaction with the
outside world except for gravitational
interaction which is a problematic
statement as such but
take it for granted for the moment and
it says these test bodies determine a
path structure
so whenever you take one of these three
particles and you throw it in a certain
direction then
no matter which which of the three
particles you took they all follow the
same trajectory
and
that's the statement of of
universality of freefall
and the past structure then has to be in
order to exit in exomatic way to arrive
at general relativity you then have to
to conclude or you have to justify that
this past structure is actually the
geodesic structure of a metric
it could be something more general it
could be geodesic of a fincelerian
metric for example more general than
romanian metrics or pseudo-romanian
metrics
and that is not so easy to argue and
that is not contained in the
universality of freefall universality
free fall just says this any any power
structure
now violations to this principle are
usually operationally
um encoded in what's called the etresh
factor after the baron adventure and
hungarian physicists at the turn of the
19th to 20th century who made
experiments with torsion balances
probing the equality of
gravitational and inertial mass
and one way to to measure the irritation
factor is just to drop two things and to
see whether they fall with the same
acceleration
and here's the acceleration of a body a
and the acceleration of a body b
and a b should be in their composition
quite different for example the ratio of
protons to neutrons should be different
and then you take the difference and you
divide by the mean
and that's the earthwesh factor it's a
real number it has two entries the
substance number one and substance
number two
and so for certain classes of substances
one tests whether they actually have the
same acceleration
and sometimes the substances are chosen
such that they fit to certain ideas why
they should not fall with the same
acceleration for example if their ratio
of protons to neutrons is quite
different so this is
the quantity that measures possible
violations and what we want to get is
lowest upper bounds for this puzzle
violation then there is local lorenz
invariants and that says basically local
non-gravitational experiments exhibit no
preferred direction in space-time
neither time-like nor space-like
a space-like direction would correspond
to an isotropy of space space in this
direction has different qualities than
space in this direction
time-like direction would say not all
inertial observers are of the same
quality some observers
move
such that you can actually um first you
can you can measure an absolute rest
frame for example it's not so
implausible for example with respect to
the microwave background
we can measure our velocity with respect
to the microwave backgrounds a few
hundred kilometers per second we see it
in the dipole anisotropy of the
microwave background
and perhaps that is really a physically
preferred rest frame why not
and that would correspond to preferred
time-like direction
there is also the possibility which i
won't talk about that it could be a
preferred light-like direction
what if there existed an ether
and the ether would blow at you at the
velocity of light from a certain
direction
can you test that or not and it's more
difficult
but it's also in principle part of this
local lawrence invariants and one way to
encode possible violations would be to
look at delta c over c where delta c is
the variation of the fourth and back
velocity of light in a kind of
michaelson molly interferometer
so you you look for the velocity of
light in a certain direction going forth
and back and then in another direction
fourth and back
and you see whether this velocity of
light depends on the direction you
measure it
and that's the delta c over c
and then there's a universality of
gravitational redshift
sometimes also called the universality
of clock rates which is slightly
different notion but okay university of
gravitational headshift and that says
that standard clocks which is similar to
test bodies
kind of elusive things but we imagine
data exists or at least approximately
they're universally affected by the
gravitational field
that means all
stan all good clocks
have the property that if you compare
their rates of ticking
then the only way by which they can
differ depends on the gravitational
potential and nothing else
in fact this is um
this is
it is slightly more is slightly more
refined than this but this is one way of
putting it
and this can be parameterized by a
factor alpha that says this the the
variation in frequency over the
frequency
varies with the potential
in a way
if this alpha of a0 in a way that's
independent of the clock doesn't depend
on the clock and it's also independent
of where the clock is it's always given
by this formula there's no space or time
dependence in this vector it's just all
residing in here
if it were violated it could possibly
depend on the clock and it could also
depend on the space-time point
and then this factor alpha would become
important now if all these three
principles are satisfied then
with some sort of mathematical rigor
it's not a theorem in a mathematical
sense but it's very very plausible at
least
it follows that you can actually
geometrized gravity
which is a very very non-trivial aspect
of gravity that means you can encode
gravity
in a geometric structure that as such is
not so triple it is not so so
uh
astonishing
what is astonishing is that all meta
components of the world be it
a photon a neutrino a baryon a lepton
whatever they all see the same geometry
there's not a neutron
geometry and a proton geometry they all
see the very same geometry it's
universal
gravity acts on all meta component by
one and only one geometry that's the
non-trivial statement that follows from
the equivalence principle
why could it be violated
what would violate such a prince such a
such a
equivalence principle well suppose for
example that next to the gravitational
interaction
of say the earth and the body a they
interact gravitationally by this
gravitational potential
proportion to the product of the masses
inverse proportional to the distances
they were just another scalar force
that has a very similar structure
coupling constant is now called h
which couples to some kind of charges
these
bodies
carry they are called q rather than m
but it's also inverse proportional to
the distance which means that the
exchange particle is a is a massless
scalar
um different
from from the gravitational from the
gravitational fields
and suppose that these charges
are
not universally proportional to the mass
for example the baryon number
could be such a charge
so suppose there were
a fifth force that couples to the berry
number or the lepton number or some
linear combinations of these
then you could write the combined
interaction with this
as
a newtonian like gravitational
interaction but now the coupling
constant would slightly depend
on the ratio the q the smaller q's on
the ratio of the charges to the masses
and if this ratio of the charge to the
mass for all matter in the world is not
universally constant it's not the same
for all meta components in the world
then you can actually very easily
calculate from this that the irritage
factor of these different bodies would
be proportional to some constant
um which is basically just the ratio of
h over g
times the difference between this
specific charges
so charge per mass so if charge per mess
is not a universal constant then these
bodies would fall um in the in the field
of of other masses in a way that is not
um
in accordance with the universality of
freefall
and such scalar fields are predicted
long-ranging scalar fields are predicted
in many of the unifying theories
cancer client theories in string
theories and so on though the different
models for example in string theory
differ in this quantity in the in the
coupling strength
so
there is a non-universal coupling
of this additional scalar to matter and
so the interaction of all meta
components look like a modified gravity
law in which the weak clearance
principle is not satisfied
and damo and polychov pointed out in
1994 that some of these models even
predict a violation of universality or
free fall at a level of the earthreach
factor of 10 to the minus 15.
looks like a small number but it's not
outrageously small
so and that's that's could so that there
are models where these violations are
actually predicted
now what is the level of verification of
the equivalence principle
so famous experiment in at washington
university the group is called wash
between 1994 and 2008 they took also
torsion pendulums this purely classical
experiment and for example they took
aluminum and platinum and so it's 10 to
the minus 12.
they took beryllium titanium 10 to the
minus 13. and for various reasons they
took various components and and made
these measurements and the improved the
planned improved levels
is the the microscope mission that's a
satellite mission with purely classical
test masses in the shape of concentric
cylinders and by optical laser devices
the relative positions of these two
masses are monitored and if they fall
with different accelerations or
velocities then microscope will detect
it up to the level of 10 to the minus
16. yes
depends on the range of course i could
have taken a massive scalar and then add
e to the minus
mu times r
and then of course this this
mixing of this additional source would
sort of be suppressed at large distances
it would depend on the mass of that
particle
but sometimes it's just assumed that
they are i mean
you can also exclude massive ones if you
are in the right range
but that of course has also been
considered and many of these these
fields in the grand unified series have
massive sectors but they have also have
mass less sectors so for us it is
important that they also predict mass
less
such fields
right so tensors minus 15 16 is is
within reach this experiment will start
in
next year
and there's a long planned um
satellite test of the equivalence
principle which wants to put this to 10
to the minus 18 but for funding reasons
this experiment has been
postponed again and again
so 10 to the minus 12 10 to the minus 13
is the current level of the equivalence
principle and it's expected to be pushed
to ten to the minus fifteen sixty
the best michael somalia experiments
with micro cavities is is ten to the
minus sixteen
but this tests
only the preferred timeline directions
so whether there's a preferred restrain
preferred frame effects so prefer
preferred frame effects are excluded up
to this order
and far worse than these upper bounds
that means higher upper bounds
are
given by
given for the universality of
gravitational lead shift
so this is an old experiment with
sounding rockets you actually
send a rocket up to 10 000 kilometers
and you have an h major clock in the
rocket and on the earth and you compare
their their their rage uh their their
rates
the experiment is called um gravity
probe a
and that led to um redshift
universality of gravitational shift
upper bounds or violations to 10 to the
minus 4 and then more recent one with
slightly different design 10 to the
minus
6. and now
comes already an interesting part in the
discussion between relativity or gravity
and quantum theory
in february 2010 in nature in this
journal nature
some
quantum optics people or quantum
molecular interferometry people claimed
that actually they can improve
this bound by four orders of magnitude
without doing a single experiment
namely they say this experiment that
shows that has actually been done 10
years before you just need to interpret
it properly and then you see that
actually this bound can be pushed down
by four orders of magnitude and the the
physics reason why one should be able to
do this is quantum mechanics
and um
i come to this
let me just before we discuss this this
is highly controversial but before i
come to this let me just say what is not
controversial not controversial is that
the clock accuracy
is in the meantime so good i should say
clock stability rather is so good that
we can measure in the laboratory the
gravitational redshift over a distance
of 10 of
33 centimeters that high
because um the clocks are based on
the the best the
best stability of clocks is about 10 to
the minus 17
and
if you look for the formula of
gravitational redshift have you done
this in the in the lectures it's
something like
tutorials so the gravitation the
redshift of
if you have two clocks one on the table
one on the floor and you synchronize
them then you put one on the table and
you leave the other on the floor and you
wait a little bit and then you
put them back together next to each
other and you read off their
their
their offset their offset is something
like 10 to the minus 16 seconds per
meter
so if one meter higher gives you a delay
of 1 to the minus x 16 seconds per
second
right
so and
from that you see 10 to the minus 17
we can do with less than a meter so that
is uncontroversial clocks are in the
meantime so good that you can compare
their rates
in the laboratory and see the
gravitational rate shift effect in the
laboratory
right so let me go
to this to this statement because that
leads us directly into the topic
of of this talk namely the relation
between quantum mechanics and gravity
so this is the experiment there is a
cesium fountain
like in the fountain clock cesium
fountain clock
and there is a beam splitter that
coherently splits
the beams of cesium atoms by inducing a
transition a hyperfine transition of the
ground stand and the hyperfine split
neighboring energy level
so one
roughly roughly 50 is an absorption
probability of 50 percent
so with 50 probability
the um the laser
the photon from the laser will be
absorbed the atom will feel a recoil and
will go up slightly higher in the
gravitation field than the other
component of the wave function of cesium
atoms that have not absorbed this
this photon and then by another laser
pulse you sort of reverse the thing and
so there is one path
of one component of the wave function of
those cesium atoms which
do not initially absorb the photon and
the other ones which do
and so there is a difference in height
they reach and this difference is 0.12
millimeters
very close a tenth of a millimeter they
are apart
and now you can actually calculate the
um the frequency shift oh sorry the
phase shift of the of the
wave function of the center of mass
motion for the cesium atoms
that
occurs because this branch
or this component goes in
travels through a higher gravitation
potential than this one
and this can be calculated this has to
do with the
the wave number vector of the photon
it's basically the
delta p
over h bar where delta p is the
momentum transfer that is induced by
recoil from the laser onto the cesium
atom
the time it takes between two laser
pulses
and the gravitational acceleration that
the cesium atoms actually suffer in the
laboratory
right so this is a dimensionless
dimensionless quantity
and and that can be calculated from
quantum mechanics an easy way to do this
for example is by path integral this is
nice application path integral uh
calculations so that can can be
calculated
this can be measured this is known this
can be measured but this is not known
the actual gravitational acceleration
with this which
of the falling season atoms is not known
it can be deduced if you measure that
but um and this was the original device
the original device on the original
paper was called a quantum mechanical
gravitometer a quantum quantum
mechanical device to measure the earth's
acceleration
but now we want to actually
not measure the
gravitational acceleration we want to
measure something else
so we don't take this as being measured
now the according to the newtonian
equations of motion the gravitational
acceleration of the cesium atom is
proportional to the gravitational field
strength of the earth
times the ratio between
gravitational mass and inertial mass of
the cesium atoms
right this ratio goes into this relation
but the gravitational field of the earth
is also not directly measurable you
measure it again by taking a reference
body and you look at the at the
gravitational acceleration of a
reference body and the reference body
that was done in the original experiment
of 1999 cassava chinchu was a corner
cube light reflector made from quads and
monitored by lasers
so it's a it's a reflecting object
microscopic object that you
let fall into your laboratory and you
monitor its motion by lasers
and that was done so this
relation that you just used for the
gravitational acceleration of the cesium
atom you just use in a reversed order
for the gravitational acceleration of
the reference body
again you get this factor of the ratio
of inertial and gravitational mass now
of the reference body in inverse in the
in in the inverse order
and now this is measured the
gravitational acceleration of the
reference body is very accurately
measured
and all other quantities are measured so
that you can actually deduce this ratio
this is the ratio of the gravitational
to inertial mass for the cesium atom
divided by the same ratio for the
reference body
and that's just the air thresh factor
that's the earthwish factor of cesium
relative to the reference body
and now we have a device that can
measure the earthwash factor for a
quantum mechanical system in a spatially
entangled state to a macroscopic body
and it would be interesting to see
whether they are also the same
and these people claim
that this address factor has been
measured by this experiment up to 10 to
the -9
okay
so why is this
sorry
that
th that is that is undisputed that you
can actually measure this air twist
factor but now these people claim you
can actually measure more
you cannot only measure the air thresh
factor you can also measure the
universality of gravitational redshift
and now comes the argument why they
think that
and these are the proponents or the the
two famous proponents and opponent in
this discussion
interestingly they're both nobel prize
winners of the same year for the same
thing
so this is steve chu who was at the time
secretary of energy in the obama
administration
and this is co-international contano g
and in this dispute they take opposite
sides um
steve chu says
he's in fact on the paper that i'm
talking about he says you can measure
the universality of gravitational
redshift by this experiment and he says
that's total nonsense
and here's my version of their argument
why should you be able to measure this
they say well from the broil we learned
every piece of matter any piece of
energy
has a periodic phenomenon built into it
he talks about phenomena periodic
any piece of matter whatever
that shall mean
and that goes by a certain in fact it's
the compton frequency that he writes
down
and then he says therefore it's a clock
and they call it compton clock every
piece of matter is a clock that's
oscillates by the quantum frequency and
that quantum clock suffers gravitational
redshift
and since the quantum clock is very fast
ticking so for the cesium atom it's
something like 10 to the 25 hertz
we can very very accurately
measure the the
in the language of gr the the path
length in space time
because if it if you have a tiny um if
you have um less than a full period in
phase shift this would mean that we have
measured a time difference less than one
period we just tend to the um
minus 24 seconds and so this is the
argument
he says
if there is a phase shift and if the
phase shift is according to
the
uncertainty or the shift in frequency
then the phase shift is delta omega
times the time
and my measurement takes to to
the atoms are in this in these different
states
according to general relativity
this phase shift is proportional to
the difference in gravitation potential
over c squared that's the formula right
the formula is delta omega over omega is
delta u over c squared
so delta omega is omega times delta u
over c squared delta u the difference in
the potential just comes about because
the atoms are different heights
so delta u is just
g times delta h
but the different height comes about
because one of the components gets
a
momentum transfer from the laser
so if the laser has wave number k
then the
associated
momentum transfer will be delta p equals
h times delta times k
so for delta eight delta h you just say
it's delta p over m that's the velocity
times the times the time it takes the
experiment so delta h is equal to delta
p over m times t times t so there's a t
squared now
and this can be brought now into this
form
this has now exactly this form
if this pre-factor is one
but what is that pre-factor the
pre-factor is
the frequency of the hypothetical clock
that i'm just talking about is exactly
the company frequency
if the frequency of that clock is
ticking
at common frequency rate
then the gravitational
the redshift of my wave function is just
the one that i deduced in the previous
slide
and therefore they say well it's obvious
that this is true if you know it is a
comp clock but the boy told us that
and therefore they say what is actually
been measured here bigger by this
interpretation this is a gravitational
redshift
now do you believe that
argument is that a good argument
um one thing that is very suspicious
about this argument i mean this argument
is 99.9
wrong i think but one one obvious reason
why it must be wrong
um leaving along all the details
is the following
except for the laser interaction points
the cesium atom is in an energy
eigenstate it's either in the ground
state or in the hyper
hyperfine split state
but it's always an energy ground state
so from here to here and from here to
here it's in an energy eigenstate a
clock
can never be in an energy eigenstate
nothing moves in an energy eigenstate
it's the whole purpose of a clock to
change its state with time otherwise you
cannot read off time
so they can't be clocks in the ordinary
sense
this does not say that this argument is
entirely wrong it may be that it's just
wrongly phrased
right but
there's certainly no such thing as a
common clock
it's not that any piece of matter can be
used as a readable clock
so that is certainly not true and one of
the challenges that people are now
actually taking up in molecular
interferometry is to repeat this
experiment but with proper clock states
a clock state is a state that's a
superposition of two energies so that
the clock the the ray in hilbert space
rotates in the plane
at the um
at the uh with the frequency this
proportion to the difference of the
energies
right so it's delta e over h that's the
frequency
and so what you want to do is to make
this experiment where these components
are actually proper clock states rather
than energy eigenstates
um
and so this is this is a sort of a first
first hint that there's something
difficult about the interpretation of um
redshift in quantum mechanics here's
another one that's also quite that's in
fact last year's uh discussion in the
literature where people pointed out
something that's also not so obvious and
you might think for yourself whether you
believe this argument or not here's the
argument
it's the argument is
that there's a remarkable consequence if
you put together relativity in quantum
mechanics and the remarkable consequence
is any clock in the gravitation field
has a has a principle
as a limit of accuracy in principle
and the the very superficial reason is
this
if if you want to
suppress the uncertainty of the clock
reading according to gravitational
redshift you have to localize the clock
very accurately if you don't know where
it is in the gravitation field you don't
know
at what gravitational level it is at
what gravitation potential if you don't
know at what gravitation potential it
sits you don't know its ticking rate
so you better know exactly where it is
on the other hand a special relativistic
effect is that there's
a
time dilation according to velocity
so if you want to suppress that you
better
make the uncertainty in the velocity
very small
but you cannot at the same time make the
velocity very small and the position
very small
uncertainty the position if you want
according to quantum mechanics if you
make one very small the other gets
bigger
so there is a minimum
where both the sum of both sort of
optimally suppressed
and how big is that
so if you take the special relativistic
time dilation it's delta t over t
according to special relativity it's
proportional to v squared over v over c
squared
the velocity certainly um larger than
the uncertainty in the velocity the
uncertainty in the velocity is delta p
over m
so um and this according to the
uncertainty relation delta p squared is
larger than one over q squared delta q
squared
so the uncertainty according to special
relativity and quantum mechanics that
goes in in here
is one over delta q q
delta q squared
now the uncertainty according to general
identity is delta u over c squared and
delta u is proportional to delta q
the height
so that goes proportional to delta q
this is inverse
inverse quadratically proportional to
delta q
now if you add them up quadratically say
and you minimize them you get a minimum
and the minimum is this
and the minimum is it goes like
the the comp wavelength
of the of the the system you're looking
at it must have said the mass goes in
there so it's the contour wavelengths of
the mass divided by what's called the
acceleration radius
right c squared over an acceleration has
the um the
physical dimension of a radius it's
called the acceleration radius
and that is usually very small
so it's
10 to the minus 22
if
the acceleration
the gravity if the gravitation field is
measured in units of
the gravitational acceleration on the
earth
and if the mass
is measured in 100 atomic mass units
then it's 10 to the minus
but if you look at a clock say on the
surface of a neutron star
then it is much less small it's much
bigger
because the acceleration is much bigger
not only is the neutron star heavier
than the earth a million times heavier
say as heavy as the sun
but its radius is much smaller instead
of being a few thousand kilometers it's
something like 10 kilometers
and so that gives you
a factor of 10 to 9 perhaps and then
suddenly this comes into the into the
same or below the range of the best
accuracy of clocks that we now have
so there is
they are it is thinkable that that under
certain circumstances that we think are
realized in nature the gravitation field
is so high that the principal
uncertainty
of clocks
is um
is
below the value or above the value sorry
of the uncertainty that we have um
from from the best clocks now
so the current stability bound on
optical atomic clocks is something like
10 to the minus a t
so in order to to get this number right
you have to distinguish between
stability and accuracy so that's this
instability limit
and again i would like to to ask you is
do you think this this is a convincing
argument or not
i'm not going to tell you so this is
um let me
show you
one argument more that you have seen
many times i guess and that's from the
discussion between born einstein a ge
duncan experiment this has been
criticized a lot and there are many many
problematic points about this argument
but it's very similar
and what i want to stress at this point
is
the logic is interesting
the argument was that einstein thought
he could prove that you can devise in
principle a system that violates the
energy time uncertainty
and he says that well
take a box
with a clock in it and the shutter and
the shutter is um opened and shut again
by this clock
and place it in the gravitation field
and let the clock be adjusted such that
the shutter opens the definite time and
then goes and shuts shuts off again and
inside the box there's a photon and the
photon either escapes or it doesn't
escape in the time the shutter opens
and whether it escapes or not i can
weigh
because i know energy weighs
and so
i can wait but i don't have to wait in
the moment it escapes i can wait any
time after and i have plenty of time
doing this
and so if i adjust the clock to shut to
open the shutter an arbitrary short time
i can take all the time i have later on
to weigh the box and decide whether this
has photon has escaped or not
and by that he thought he could violate
this this inequality
and bohr refuted this argument
um
and i think i don't need to go through
this that's a simple argument
but the crucial ingredient in this
argument is some version of the
equivalence principle
because
his board uses
that when the weighing procedure is in
progress and the box is raised and
lowered in the gravitational field by
the weighing procedure that will suffer
a time uncertainty through this weighing
process and he needs precisely this
weighing on this uncertainty in time
to restore the validity of this equation
so in a sense what boss says is to
rescue quantum mechanics you need
to take into account this principle
that's behind this equation namely the
equivalence principle so in some sense
bohr says
um
quantum mechanics needs for its
consistency some aspect of of general
additivity and that's very interesting
so it's just the other way around right
and i think that's an interesting he
also psychologically speak and it's an
interesting aspect of this discussion
um
so this um this was an old issue a
recent issue old issue and i would also
want to tell you something about old
hopes
there is an old hope
that sits behind the idea of unifying a
relativity and gravitation
and the old hope
is that all these divergences
that
afflict quantum field theory
were supposed to possibly go away
naturally
if you couple the system to gravity
because gravity could serve as a self
regulating mechanism to subtract all the
infinities of energy
and there's a very simple but very
telling
um
model calculation which shows
how this could work
and this is the this is the model
calculation
as you know for example in quantum field
theory in quantum theorem quantum field
series the self energies for example
particles are infinite even in quantum
field theory the self energy of the
electron comes out to be logarithmically
divergent in the radius as the radius
goes to zero
so let's let's do this calculation by
taking into account
equivalence principle
so take a mass shell so classically now
a mass shell of radius r
and perhaps it has an initial
rest mass m0
and also give it a gravitational mass
which i don't want to specify at the
moment it's a gravitational mass that
may be different from its rest mass
and also give it an electric charge
then its total energy is the rest mass
then the energy stored in the
electrostatic field outside the the
sphere which is q squared over 2r in
proper units
but there's also a gravitational self
energy that resides in the gravitational
field which is negative because the
the charge and the the masses attract
each other
so if you disperse everything to
infinity energy level is zero if you
bring them together you gain energy
gravitationally so this health energy
stored in the gravitational field is
negative and is this very same structure
as the coulomb term here it's just
gravitational constant times the
gravitational
mass
divided by 2r the gravitational mass
squared
and now use two principles
the total energy
equals
um the inertial mass times c squared
that comes from special relativity
and then add on top of this
that the inertial mass is actually the
gravitational mass of the full system
so the the gravitating mass that sits
here is actually the overall mass
it's all the energy that gravitates not
just the specific component of it all
the energy gravitates and if you
include this then we can just call all
the different masses which i equal m
then we get a quadratic equation for m
here's an m and here's an m but this is
quadratic
and that equation for the quadratic m
can be solved by the standard formula
for quadratic equations and you get a
solution
where the mass
as a function of the radius of the shell
is this expression
so this looks dangerous because there's
air
in the
denominator
however that's canceled by this r so in
fact this has a
has a existing limit
as r goes to zero
so now i can compress
the the the um
the sphere and result in a finite value
for its own energy it's not infinite
anymore and the finiteness of it is
precisely come about because of this
quadratic term that was added by gravity
and the value of course is something
strange it's um it's defined structure
constant comes in here the absolute
charge in values in in units of the
elementary charge and the planck mass
but okay so that's a finite value
had you attempted to make this
calculation order by order in
perturbation theory in g
you would have found that it diverges at
each order
right this is a completely divergent
expansion in g by each order it diverges
but the um
and the reason being that the limit is
not uniform in r
so if you come if you if you interchange
the limit r goes to zero and and and g
goes to zero it doesn't doesn't commute
um but as you see from the analytic full
analytical expression nothing goes wrong
so the the finite rest mass exists even
though in perturbation theory you
wouldn't have seen it
and that the
sort of ideas of that sort
um
encouraged people to say ah if we
include gravity quantum field theory
will be in a much better shape than it
is now
but then there were also voices against
this and they said well if you include
gravity
all these talk about um equivalence
principle doesn't hold anymore quantum
theory violates the equivalence
principle there's a famous discussion at
the conference in
1957 refinement in fact raised this
point and said
it's all nonsense we know that
we know that
quantum mechanics violates the
equivalence principle and the example um
that was discussed at this conference
was just at a diffraction grating
which was put sort of in a grave
imagine a diffraction grating put
horizontally and you sprinkle particles
over it and underneath the different
diffraction grating there is a there's a
there's a
you see the interference pattern
on the screen
and if you sprinkle the particle just
over the diffraction grating
then
the
the the
distances of the of the or the pattern
will depend on the on the inertial
masses of the particles that you that
you that you distribute over it because
the debris wavelength depends on that
the velocities that the particles
acquire in the gravitation field will
not depend on the mass but the momentum
they acquire will depend on the mass and
it's the momentum that makes the broil
wavelengths
so looking at the diffraction grating in
the pattern you will actually be table
it will actually be able to tell the
mass of the particles that you have been
dropping
another example is
think of the gravity of the
gravitational hydrogen atom
so the hydrogen atom here is just the
thing of two systems that attract
gravitationally one has um
mass lowercase m the other has mass
capital m
and um
make it very simple it's just a stress
orbital it's just a
circle
as an orbit then you have centrifugal
force equals gravitational attraction
but then you say angular momentum must
be quantized in
integer units of h-bar and then
use this to actually solve this equation
for r and eliminate omega and then you
get that the radius as a function of
this n is that expression and the
angular frequency is that expression and
what you see is
it's not the quotient of
inertial mass and gravitational mess
that enters it's um here's the product
and here's the product of one times the
square of the other
and that
has sometimes in the past and even today
been used to say aha so
quantum mechanics actually in quantum
mechanics
the motion the motion of two test bodies
does depend after all on not just the
quotient of inertial gravitational mass
it depends on other aspects
right
other polynomial functions for example
and here the energy you can see the
energy also depends like the frequency
on
inertial mass times the gravitational
mass and that in fact is just currently
tested not of course with a hydrogen
atom because that would be as large as
the as the solar system if you took
elementary particles but for the ultra
cold neutrons that i've told you at the
beginning
so this is the same situation again it's
the airy function that solves the linear
potential eigenvalue problem
so you have a heart a hard mirror on one
side and a linear slope on the other
side and you look for the
energy energy eigenstates and here the
formula for the energy eigenstates
basically it's just this
down here so that's the airy function
that's the that's the penetration into
the into the
regime of
where the potential energy is larger
than the kinetic energy so it's a
classically forbidden region but the
wave function will penetrate into the
classically forbidden region for some
for some uh distance
and so the the eigenvalues of the
energies are this and again you see it
depends now on the quotient between the
gravitational mass and the inertial mass
and so as we as we talk
measurements are made in
various places for example in in the
technical university in vienna
um to actually measure that quotient
from that experiment
however the
of course the equivalence principle does
not say that you cannot measure mg or mi
it says that if you can measure them
they always come out to be proportional
so there's no
contradiction anywhere here against the
equivalence principle however what does
quantum mechanics tell you is that there
are nice methods to separate the two
so this formula that i've shown you are
nice formula which
depends not just on the quotient they
depend on other
combinations of these two different
masses
and
i know that in in in march there will be
a conference in
in berlin the freestyle dpk the german
physical society and this person from
from hartmut abele from uh technical
university in vienna he will talk about
measurements of
inertial and gravitational mass of
neutrons
so here quantum mechanic is actually a
new opportunity
but now okay so this is all very
different kinds of aspects about
equivalence principle if somebody asks
you you give a quantum mechanics lecture
what do you tell the students what what
happens about the equivalence principle
is it or is it not true in quantum
mechanics
and
i think the right answer would be to
first say
what is the kind of object for which the
equivalence principle is proposed in the
classical theory
it's a test particle it's not any
particle follows the same trajectory we
know that this is not true
um
it's test particle and a test particle
is a very sophisticated constructmental
construction
what is a test particle a test particle
should satisfy certain
as test particles should not disturb
for example the geometry that you want
to test with it that means
it should not be too small because if it
becomes too small
then the gravitational field on its
surface is as large as the gravitational
field that you actually want to test in
other words the curvature just outside
the particle
is of the same order of magnitude or
even bigger than the curvature that you
actually want to probe so it should not
be too small but of course it should
also not be too large because it becomes
too large then the extent of the
particle is of the same order of
magnitude as the curvature radius of the
background and then you wouldn't be able
to actually probe accurately what the
curvature of the background is
it should not be spinning because if it
had a spin the spin would couple to
curvature we know this and that would
make a deviation from the geodesic law
it should not be electrically charged
because a strong electric field on a
surface makes strong stresses and energy
densities which again curve space
it should not have
um multiple moments in in this mass
distribution because if you had a
quadrupole moment in its mass
distribution for example again it would
come into curvature and the geodesic law
would not be satisfied and you can many
you can list many things it should not
have and at the end of the day you ask
yourself so what's the non-trivial
statement that's left
because the non-trivial statement says
something all test particles fall the
same way
so how many different test particles are
there
that actually satisfy all the criteria
that i've just listed not many
and certainly a wave packet in quantum
mechanics is not a good test particle as
an extent and the extent can be
controlled because it flows
flows around
so the equivalence principle in quantum
mechanics can on the face value of it
first of all only be stated in terms of
say homogeneous gravitational fields and
then you would say something like on a
homogeneous gravitational field or
approximately homogeneous gravitational
field the wave function
falls
like
in an accelerating rest frame
sorry in an accelerating frame so
something like the original einstein
elevator idea
is that satisfied in quantum mechanics
says or no the answer is yes it is and
here's the mathematical statement
um
it's not entirely trivial to show this
it's um it's not difficult and but it's
not it's not a one line it's not a one
calculation
so there's the following proposition
states in my opinion precisely the
extent to which universality of free
fall is related within quantum mechanics
so you consider a particle of mass m
in especially homogeneous force field f
in fact
this what i'm the theorem that i'm now
telling you
um holds for any uniform force field
whatever the origin of the force is
um
so if it's a uniform force field it only
depends on time but not on space
then the classical trajectories are
solutions to this equation this is just
newton's equation of motion acceleration
equals force divided by mass
now this can be solved you can solve for
the trajectories of the classical
falling sort of dust if you like
and now you can
make the following statement
um psi solves the schrodinger equation
with force fields
if and only if
another function
solves the schroedinger equation without
force field
and the other function
is given by the original function
um
by
transporting it along the flow field so
this
phi capital phi is the the flow that's
generated by the solutions of this of
this vector equation
in other words if you um if you want to
to know how um a wave function according
to schrodinger falls in the
gravitational fields
you can say okay it falls in the same
way as a wave function behaves if i i
myself accelerate in an acceleration
frame of reference and the function
evolves in this according to the free
shooting equation
there is a non-trivial phase factor
coming in which you may be used to
perhaps if you
for example know how the
the schrodinger function transforms
under galilei transformations under
inertial
transformations it does not transform as
a scalar function
the schrodinger function is not a scalar
function on space time on x and t
something more complicated and that is
accounted for here by having a sort of
complicated phase function
but the quantum mechanical state the ray
transform exactly
as
as you would expect from going from one
reference frame to the other one that's
just this composition with the inverse
inverse flow transformation
and in that sense um the weak
equivalence principle is built into
quantum
mechanics no no no no
that's also true but no more complicated
than that
it's i mean you might know that the
in fact the the i had some
transparencies on this by um there are
many ways to look at this but one way to
look at this is to
to first of all look at the proper
relativistic equation the kind gordon
equation and to remember what has the
schrodinger function to do with the
klingon function
and they differ by a phase factor
involving the time and that makes the
non-scalar transformation property
what i'm actually in in other words what
i'm referring to it's um
the the um
when the galileo transformations for
example the schrodinger function
transforms according to a non-trivial
ray representation which is not
equivalent to a proper representation
it's a ray representation and under
acceleration transformation
it's the same
it's array representation
the proposal of truth was similar to
this
equation certainly where
he he added a phase that's right
exactly
that's right can mum decide with this
equation if he's correct
no because it's not i don't think it's
really a question about mathematics
at this point it's a question of whether
you can in that nobody disagrees on the
equation delta phi equals that so this
equation has been derived in many ways
and i think everybody believes this
equation the question is whether you
should think of this equation of this
delta phi as being a redshift delta phi
or something it's it appears just as a
phase shift but the question is what
interpretation do we give that right
that phase shift so i think as far as
the derivation of this equation is
concerned everybody agrees that it is a
proper equation in quantum mechanics
right so um
so that looks good how would we go about
and ask
how do quantum mechanical systems
coupled to gravity in general
now here is here's a way to see how it
couples in in homogeneous gravitation
field it is just according to the
equivalence principle as we have learned
it sort of in in undergraduate courses
with homogeneous gravitational fields
and and accelerating
elevators and so on
but how would you go to do it in general
and that is not an easy question that is
in fact a very difficult question
because
initially i said if somebody gives a
journaling equation you just take the
potential and you take the gravitational
potential in it right but we know the
gravitational potential is not exhausted
by its scalar component
the gravitational potential is more than
just the newtonian potential it's the
metric so how does the metric enter into
the
into the um
into the uh joining equation
and then one way to do it is is to
to use the principle that you might have
learned in this course it's minimal
coupling did you mention this on the
covariance replacing partial derivative
by covariant derivatives replacing the
minkowski metric by the curved
space-time metric very implicit
okay so if you take any sort of matter
how does electromagnetism feel gravity
there's a prescription how you how you
do this it's called
minimal coupling
and
minimal coupling says take your favorite
theory
give it a special relativistic form
replace the minkowski metric of that
special relativistic form by the curved
spacer metric and replaced in ordinary
derivatives by covariance derivatives
this is the prescription so step one
would mean first take your favorite
theory and put it into special
relativistic form
now if you have a one particle quantum
mechanical system what is its special
editionistic form
quantum field theory many particle
theory but not one particle theory so
already that step is not easy
and therefore for some for some
sort of situations where people think
okay
actually it's that it's just the
classical gravitation field that i want
to couple it's not so much the
the um the quantum field theory of the
gravitational sector that i'm interested
in it's the quantum field theory sector
of my meta that i'm interested in with a
classical gravitational field how i do
this and then people said okay the first
good guess would be the so-called
semi-classic einstein equations
so it's the einstein and tensor on the
left-hand side and the on the right hand
side it's the energy momentum tensor
for the expectation value perhaps of a
quantum field
and that's harmless as it looks is a
very dangerous procedure
interpretation wise and also mathematics
works
if the right hand side is the
expectation value of the quantum field
phi in a certain quantum state
then the energy momentum tensor that's
on the right hand side clearly depends
on the state because it's the
expectation value
if you then solve the einstein equations
the solution to the einstein equations
which is the metric becomes implicitly
state-dependent because the right-hand
side is dependent but that metric now
goes back into the evolution equation
for the quantum state
now the evolution equation of the
quantum state had formally perhaps been
linear but now when you feed in the
metric in which depends on the match it
becomes non-linear
so
this coupling would induce a
non-linearity in your evolution equation
for the quantum state
and one version of this a mickey mouse
version if you like of this
is
the non-relativistic limit weak
gravitational fields small velocities
of that equation
that means where gravity is just
described by the scalar potential of the
of the newtonian gravitational potential
and where the right hand side becomes
the one particle
non-relativistic wave function to go to
one particle sector we don't have
transitions between different particle
sectors and then we essentially get
something like the client gordon
equation for the one particle sector and
of that we take the non-relativistic
limit
there are many ways to do this and we
get to the schroedinger equation and
that program can be run and the result
of this is this equation
which is the schrodinger equation which
which has an additional potential and
the additional potential is just what
you thought it would be
namely basically the potential according
to a mass distribution
rho which is basically just a zero zero
component of the energy momentum tensor
it's a zero zero component divided by c
squared so it's just a matter density of
the energy momentum tensor that's just
the first factor so this is the
newtonian equation for the newtonian
gravitation potential for that mass
distribution but there's another term
and the other term is
a term
which distributes some meta sort of meta
according to the probability
distribution the probability
amplitude squared
of that schrodinger function
as if the schrodinger function
represented some meta distribution
according to the probability density
that's the outcome of that equation
so if for the moment we ignore the first
term here
which is the obvious one that we
expected this is just another way to
derive from first principles we get
another term the self-coupling of the
gravitational field of a meta
of a meta wave
and
solving this equation
so inverting the laplacian
by an integral
we can actually solve for this v in
terms of an integral over psi squared
and plug it into this equation and then
we get a non-linear
non-local
integral differential equation
and this is this one and it's called the
schrodinger newton equation
so this is the schrodinger equation with
the free part the kinetic part and this
is a self-interaction of the psi fields
according to some self-gravitating
factor that spreads all over space
and that equation is quite interesting
its derivation is
plausible
in some situations it has been much much
discussed and many people don't like it
other people think it is interesting to
pursue whether this equation has
testable consequences in the laboratory
and so it's worth pointing out that this
is a perfectly decent equation even
though it's non-local and non-linear
can be derived from an action principle
it has all the symmetries of the
schrodinger equation it has a 10
parameter symmetry group the
inhomogeneous galilei group it has a
nice scaling property
you can derive
new solutions from o2 by scaling
and many mathematical results about
these equations are known
it's not
it's different from other nonlinear
screening equations that people use for
example for both einstein condensates
for for so-called pla and
also for plasmas but also for um for
condensates
this is the this is called the gross
piece equation which has a non-linearity
but which is local this one is non-local
um one way to
let me just go back one way to to
to see under what conditions this
pre-factor become this factor becomes
important when does sort of this
perturbation of the free schooling
equation become important
one trick to to to to do is to put the
schrodinger equation to a dimensionless
form
introduce a length scale introduce
accordingly a time scale
introduce a dimensionless space
coordinate and a dimensionless time
coordinate and rescale the
the the schrodinger function so it's now
square integral
now with respect to the
un
rescaled
x-coordinate
then the newton equation takes this form
and now you have a pre-factor k here and
this prefecture k here is dimensionless
and you want to ask under what condition
is that factor
close to one
at least not too small
and
if you if you
play around a little bit with it you see
that it can be brought into the form
length scale divided by planck length
times the mass parameter that's in this
equation divided by planck mass to the
third power
so if this factor is not very small then
this term becomes effective
and this means
that
if your system for example is of the
order of a few hundreds of nanometers
typical um
grating distances for example in
experiments like in vienna when people
do diffraction uh experiments with
molecules or
and so on in the group of marcus and for
example then you have a few nanometers
so you have wave packets of the width of
a few hundred nanometers
and the mass you must have in order to
see this factor must then be 10 to the
atomic mass units u
atomic mass units they have ten to the
five
ten to the five atomic mass units they
take large molecules and make um diff um
coherence experiments with large
molecules for example if you take
fluorophorene
they have
1632 or something atomic mass units
so it is
if this equation were correct
then you would see deviations from the
free schrodinger equation according to
the self gravity
for 100 nanometer wave packets
if the mass is 10 to the 10u
and we are five orders of magnitude away
from this
that's right that's right coherence time
the coherence time you would need are
very long here
it depends very much on the masses but
it would be here very long that's true
that's right yes yes yes
that's right i i come to this
the upshot is on earth it's very
unlikely to be have an experiment like
this but in space not
um
so there is some some kind of
self-gravitating effect of wave
functions if you believe the
semi-classical equation
this semi-classical equation has other
nice properties that just briefly want
to mention just short mention of this
for example take a free gaussian wave
packet this is the solution to the free
schooling equation the full glory of
this
solution of an initial gaussian state
for all future times
and now plot the radial
the radial probability distribution
that's psi mod squared times r squared
so the radial probability distribution
this is a global maximum at this value
and you can calculate the acceleration
of this global maximum
and
you can you can
compare
the um the acceleration according to
quantum mechanical
dispersion
um and compare this to the
self-gravitating inwards pointing
acceleration according to its own
mass
and you see that
the
quantum mechanical dispersion goes like
one over width to the cubed
and the um gravitational attraction goes
like one over the width roughly the
width um to the to the to the to the
second power
which means that the gravity the wave
packet will will recombine
but it will never form a delta
distribution
eventually quantum mechanical dispersion
is always stronger because it grows
faster with the third power
but then sort of the the quantum
mechanical dispersion sets in and if if
if it if the wave packet is sufficiently
wide then the gravitational effect um
comes into the play and re
and uh refocuses
um the the this wave packet and leads to
apparently the coherences in the in the
experiments
and again you get the same relation from
this naive um picture that the mass q to
the width should be
the mass cube to the length scale in
plank units
so if this is fulfilled if if the mass
cubed times a is of that order then this
effect becomes dominant
right
and you can ask okay so there will be a
an oscillation
phase there will be a refocusing and
then it will be
um
does the system have actually bound
states according to its own gravity and
the answer is yes it does have
bound states and in fact you can very
naively estimate them
and the estimate is is
you might know these dirty tricks from
elementary quantum mechanics courses
where you can almost exactly judge the
redberg energies by sort of
semi-classical
non-rigorous um
back of an envelope calculations
where you make some sort of
uh
energy balance with the kinetic term and
the potential term and then you minimize
in a
and then you um
so this this you get by using the by
using the the uncertainty principle to p
squared over m is something like one
over m a squared according to
the uncertainty principle and then you
minimize an a and you can play the same
trick here and what you get is almost
exactly up to factor 1.6 of the
calculated energy ground state and
that's an energy ground state exists had
been fully analytically proven
so what will happen is there will be a
soliton in the end assuring a newton
soliton and the rest will be radiated
away
and at some stage penrose thought that
this would be a nice model for the
quantum mechanical collapse of the wave
function according to gravity
but this picture tells you that it
cannot be because the the whole wave
function would have to collapse into one
localized state instead what happens is
part of it will localize here and parts
will be radiated away
so it's it's still
these two
one
part localized here and the other one
one running away there
so this is why why the original panos
idea i think doesn't work
right and and i i also was part of this
game in the last few years and and we
asked ourselves how would that model for
a single self-gravitating particle
um actually give rise to observable
consequences in those experiments that
people for example in vienna do
and
for this you have to look at a many
particle situation and to derive an
effective equation for the center of
mass because this is what they observe
the center of mass wave function it's
not up they don't observe the center of
each individual particle so you have to
a many particle equation like this and
then deduce an effective equation for
the center of mass which is non-trivial
because this is a non-linear equation so
it's not obvious that the center of mass
wave function separates from the rest
you cannot separate in the usual way
so the question was how you separate
these equations and that's difficult and
it's only approximately done
analytically but what we could show is
that the center of mass or base is
showing a newton equation under certain
circumstances that can be met
and then you get an equation like this
for the center of mass of spheres for
example and now there are experiments
involving these these these spheres
and now i would like to see the movie
there's a short movie just for the if
you just click it
you see um the evolution
right so this is an evolution of a free
wave packet in red and the blue wave
packet according to schroedinger newton
equation
now it's prince again now comes gravity
into play now refocuses again
and falls back and that's the radial
probability distribution whereas the red
one becomes
shallower and shallower
the blue one always comes back
and forth
and they did and you see the um let's
see first of all
it's um it's 10 to the nine mass units
um
this is this is nanometers this is the
the width nanometers and the integration
time was almost a day
right this is almost a day
so you would in order to see this you
would have had coherence times of days
but for higher masses the coherence time
goes down with the fifth power of the
mass
so it goes down very fast
so if you take higher masses 10 to the
13 for example then you have
significantly less
coherence times that you need
okay that's almost it to talk again
can i see the talking
oh it's
no
just go back to the direction fire
the process that you have just seen
takes days takes a day
so the spreading and refocusing takes a
day
no not the time of coming no no no no no
okay
so this is where we were
and this is this is just a static
picture of this
this is just a static picture of this
and you see that um you have to 40 000
seconds here for refocusing of this of
this wavefile this basically just did
and this is also
increasing this is this is the the peak
of the wave function if you have five
times 10 to the nine atomic mass units
it spreads then it starts to refocus
refocus refocus if you increase the
masses and energy focuses it makes this
bounces back and forth
and that's just what you have seen in
the movie so it's just the same and that
brings me to the conclusion
so what have we learned about quantum
gravity of course
about quantum gravity proper we have
learned nothing so far
what we have but
they're much easier questions than those
than that um for quantum gravity that
are also not easily answerable
and that's uh the the relation between
ordinary quantum mechanics and and
gravity
so one question we could for example
address what happens in the unlikely
though not impossible event that gravity
stays classical
how then do quantum systems couple to
gravity what for example would be the
gravitational field that is created by a
spatial
space um but
a typical quantum mechanical situ a
double slit experiment
if you have two
delocalized meta components in your wave
function how do they
act as a source for the gravitational
field
one question that my colleagues in the
in the laboratories ask is can we
significantly improve
improvements to lower the upper bounds
on violations of the equivalence
principle by using matter in
non-classical states
that's what they want to test so they
want to test some sort of quantum
equivalence principle but before you
test that you have to formulate it
so what is the quantum equivalence
principle whose possible violations you
want to test
and one question i'm interested in is
there's an army of arguments against
fundamental semi-classical gravity
but all these arguments presuppose some
sort of validity of the standard
mechanical formalisms including the
collapse postulate
which itself is sort of for some at
least problematic
and it's not clear to me how convincing
these
arguments really are
and therefore i think it's interesting
to look for consequences from
semi-classical gravity
um and to test
um whether you can actually see
effects that can be tested by center of
mass motions and i talked to
some people working in this field on the
experimental side
mostly those in vienna
marcus and marcus aspelmeyer and
hendrick ulbrist
who also worked in vienna some time ago
and now has his own group in southampton
and they say to me
at least they say it's not altogether
ridiculous
to propose such experiments
and we made some back of an envelope
calculations how likely it is to see
something and the and if progress is as
in the last years then yes on
space
platforms it could be feasible on earth
probably not
because there usually integration times
are limited by the free by the time for
the free flight of the object
in in
so for example in the
place i come from in in bremen we have a
drop tower 140 meters high in the
dropping height is 110 meters and we
have 4.6 seconds of weightlessness
that's not enough we need more
the effect goes squared in time
so if you have significantly longer time
we can
actually improve closeness
okay and that brings me at least to the
end of of the main part of this talk
thank you
you